[Música]
[Aplausos]
se han puesto a pensar quiénes serían
ustedes si no tuvieran recuerdos
en esta sala hay un asesino y todos
nosotros somos cómplices
para el 2050 en nuestro país habrá un
incremento de 400 47% de casos de
alzhéimer saben qué significa esto que
en 38 años tú o yo seremos una persona
que tenga alzhéimer o estaremos cuidando
de alguien
y estas estadísticas no nos están
alarmando y tendrían que hacerlo
te lo pongo más sencillo te explico como
ocurre porque el cuento del alzheimer no
es como los contaron sólo el 10% de los
casos son hereditarios y el 90% es culpa
nuestra
la población mundial tiene 40 por ciento
de probabilidad de tener el gen del
alzhéimer pero dependerá del estilo de
vida de cada uno de nosotros
manifestarlo no además saben cuántas
personas tienen diabetes o presión alta
en bolivia mi mamá tiene y créame que
para mí es una preocupación continua
déjenme explicarles un poco cómo
funciona el alzheimer yo crecí con
pacman
pacman es muy parecido a lo que vivimos
con el alzheimer
pero les cuento para aquellos que están
muy jóvenes si no los conocen todavía
pacman en esta historia es el bueno
pero tiene una misión tiene que comer
cada una de las pastillas que están en
el laberinto y lograr ganar el juego
existen sus archienemigos los fantasmas
uno que otro medio aventurero y otros
que están medios escondidos y éstos
intentarán a toda costa arruinarle la
vida pacma
pero pacman tiene un superpoder y si es
que come la super pastilla tiene la
capacidad para que poderes como super
velocidad y hacer vulnerables a sus
enemigos así obtiene una ventaja y logra
ganar el juego
simple qué ocurre entonces en la vida
real en la vida real sólo cambia una
sola cosa
déjenme decirle algo
en la vida real pak amanecer no salvado
magma representa el alzheimer que es el
alzheimer entonces el alzheimer es una
enfermedad neurodegenerativa progresiva
e irreversible exactamente como pacman
cada vez que pacman da un paso al frente
y come cada una de nuestras neuronas
está eliminando un recuerdo
imaginen lo siguiente estoy caminando
por la plaza
y de repente
me encuentra perdida
por donde dará vicasa
poner el número de teléfono a mi casa
disculpe señor está usted sabe cómo
llegar a
pero como se llama la calle donde vivo
cómo se llama las personas con las que
vivo y en realidad me empiezo a dar
cuenta de que no estoy perdido a nivel
físico sino que acabo de perder mi
historia personal y además mi identidad
en ese momento es cuando mis pacientes
empiezan a llegar
en ese momento es cuando acude un
neurólogo un psiquiatra y empiezan un
tratamiento farmacológico
lastimosamente esta es una etapa muy
avanzada
suena muy triste la historia y la verdad
es muy triste verlo pero aún así cada
una nosotros somos unos luchadores
porque nuestro cerebro
albergamos la reserva cognitiva la
reserva cognitiva es una barrera que
acumulamos color con el paso de los años
esos cafés y tos en casa con la familia
que nos juntábamos nos reunimos y la
pasamos muy bien cuando vemos que la
abuelita está tejiendo una chompa unos
postres deliciosos esa pasión por la
música por el cine por el arte por hacer
todo eso genera una barrera protectora
esos años cansados de estudio en el
colegio en la universidad en la maestría
en los postgrados créanme son vitales
para poder crear esta barrera
tener la capacidad de hacer las cosas
por ti mismo que nadie te ayude sentirte
útil a cada momento es parte de nuestra
reserva cognitiva y saben por qué esto
es tan impresionante
esto es porque cada uno de nosotros pone
muchas de sus emociones en esta vida y
cuando uno entrega todo de sí genera
emociones positivas y negativas
a veces pacman tiene una ventaja
a veces cuando llegamos a la edad los 56
años en el trabajo vienen con una gran
noticia
felicidades lo has hecho muy bien
gracias por tu servicio
retírate y pasan a ser una persona
sedentaria inútil frágil después de
haber sido un gerente multinacional
y no me estoy inventando el caso es real
y en ese momento empiezas a dudar de ti
mismo y ese momento de crisis empieza a
afectar tus emociones y hace que el
alzheimer avance con tal fuerza
que probablemente el tratamiento
farmacológico no nos ayude saben que es
perder la muerte de un ser querido
imagínense perder a la persona que nos
acompaña por toda la vida que cuando
estamos casados 20 30 50 años sabe la
cantidad de recuerdos que acumulamos con
esas personas son muchísimos y esa
tristeza nos arrebata los recuerdos
y aquí es donde llega el equipo de élite
los psicólogos y neuropsicólogos a veces
somos muy tímidos para expresar quién
realmente somos entonces el trabajo que
realizamos es mostrarle a la persona de
que todo eso que guardo por tanto tiempo
todo ese dolor
todas esas alegrías las puede traer al
presente y al recordar el pasado vive
cada día de una manera diferente
está vacío
me encantaría decirles que la historia
con el alzheimer y a pesar de tener un
tratamiento farmacológico y además tener
a los especialistas en psicología
neuropsicología genera una solución
en la vida real el alzheimer siempre
gana y se lleva tus logros se lleva a tu
familia se lleva tu identidad se lleva
tu capacidad para seguir con vida
vamos a dejar que esto nos gane
es la pregunta que le hacemos a cada uno
de los familiares y cuidadores de estas
personas con alzheimer cuando una
persona recibe el diagnóstico de
alzheimer aún le queda como 5 a 10 años
de vida pero para la familia es algo muy
duro tener que saber que su familia no
lo va a recordar y que además
probablemente va a morir con esto
pero continuamos se animan creen que hay
una opción todavía
bueno en la asociación alzheimer bolivia
nosotros no nos da la gana dejárselo
fácil vamos a hacer todo lo posible
porque aunque no podamos cambiar el
final de la historia la manera en que lo
vivimos va a ser espectacular
entonces nosotros brindamos un espacio
donde estos adultos mayores siempre vean
una cara sonriente siempre tienen una
mano para acompañarlos en esos paseos
donde la familia puede ver que vivir con
alzheimer es solamente una nueva manera
de vivir como lo es vivir con cualquier
enfermedad
me gustaría contarles la historia de
ella solo mírenla
ella fue mi primer paciente lo es aún
ella no me recuerdo
bueno
[Aplausos]
aunque yo no tengo una familia con
alzheimer y no haga una historial de
alzheimer mi familia perdida día como
estas familias tienen que luchar y ver
que esta persona jamás les va a volver
llamar por su nombre y van a ser unas
personas equis en su vida realmente
tocan en nuestras vidas
me encanta que cuando yo la miro y le
digo señora nelly cómo está
ella sabe en lo más profundo de su ser
que aunque no conoce mi nombre y tampoco
conoce mi cara hay algo en ella que le
dice que estar conmigo es un lugar
seguro que estar con esas personas que
día a día dan de su tiempo para poder
tener los oídos atentos y los ojos
mirándolos
hace que vivir con alzheimer sea posible
y además sea una vida feliz
y cuando llegue el final la familia está
segura de que entregó los mejores
momentos y creó nuevos recuerdos no
solamente con su mamá con su papá sino
con un nuevo amigo
saben bolivia no está preparada para ese
447%
y ese 447% el 90% somos culpables
nosotros
les voy a dar tres formas
de luchar juntos contra el alzheimer
primero
deja de alimentar a pacman y duerme bien
tiene un tiempo contigo
deja de tener una vida tan estresante
dedica tiempo para ti descansa
ya sabes las consecuencias de esto
segundo todo lo que estás haciendo en tu
vida va a servir para algo el laberinto
es una pieza tan importante en esto
porque mientras más difícil sea más
difícil se lo vamos a hacer el juego a
él hagamos que pacman se pierda y que
con tantos recuerdos no abastezca para
destrozarlos
y tercero a cada momento
póngale una emoción mientras más fuertes
son las emociones mayor es el recuerdo
vivan intensamente y generan atajos que
su cerebro encontrará maneras para
luchar contra el alzheimer unidos en
familia conectados con nuestros amigos
con nuestra comunidad lograremos luchar
contra el alzheimer muchas gracias
[Aplausos]